you were just at the super bowl i did i
went to the super bowl tell us about it
um okay
um was it fun did you enjoy it
new orleans is the new orleans is like
the coolest city in the country i think
it's like it's like yeah give it up for
new orleans everybody they did uh
amazing job hosting and it's like
there's two cities in the u.s that are
kind of like consequence-free like vegas
and
new orleans and and vegas there's
something synthetic and kind of weird
going on there but new orleans like the
the debauchery in new orleans feels
like organic and historic you know like
it's a natural
like you're gonna leave with a disease
but it's like you got it at a museum
well so people just let loose there yeah
you crazy yeah you just in like every
meal or you're having a drink you're
like i don't know it's like breakfast
time and you're like should i have like
a bowl of pig lard and like four shots
of rail vodka
and the waiter is always just like it's
new orleans
[Laughter]
so
you were at the game for the blackout
what was it like to be there during the
blackout uh it was it was pretty crazy
it's like the you know the lights go out
and what people don't realize the lights
went out
and uh and then when they came back up
the two harbaugh brothers were kissing
it was like that's crazy and someone's
like it's new wallet
now speaking of travel i understand you
went to peru not too long ago why did
you go to peru um i my buddy gary
emailed me and was like do you want to
go away and i was like sure he's like
what about machu picchu which is this
amazing incan you know ruins in peru and
and i was like i don't know anything
about it but that name machu picchu is
so cute it's like the cutest word i was
just like how can i not go to a place
that's just like machu picchu
what are you i'm an ink
were you recognized in peru i actually
did get recognized a few times it was
pretty wild uh and you know sketch
comedy uh american sketch comedy and
shows about fantasy football are huge in
peru in bolivia
i imagine you're a god there yeah yeah i
mean a deity a god i don't know but a
deity so um
so we actually i went i actually went
and uh uh shot some stuff there just to
try to get the word out on the
international markets because it's all
about international markets you're
telling this guy let's take a look at
this video that you shot in peru this is
nick kroll getting the word out
[Music]
like if you like the league then you'll
probably like
crawl show that's what crawl shows like
it's like a bunch of uh
automatic
fart noises
you have a nielson box
you go on reddit if you tweet about it
it's hashtag trollshow
[Music]
you made a big difference i think i did
was that a yak what was that that was a
bull and an alpaca and then that oh
that's a bowl i think that's a bowl you
can see he's gonna tune in yeah he's
psyched about the show he was a mr show
guy so he's been
a huge comedy fan for you how is the uh
food in peru i don't know anything about
this the food is good uh there's a
delicacy the uh delicacy there called
kui which is uh another adorable word uh
and it's for it's a guinea pig uh
because i guess that's the noise that
the guinea pigs make is like
so so they call it the noise they call
the noise it makes which is weird like
because like i don't know if i would eat
turkey if it was cold
that's the cheapest joke